in the lobby of Ramsay Solutions Alex
and Marie are with us in costume for
Halloween welcome you guys where do
y'all live here in Nashville all right
and you are dressed for those that can't
look deeply into the radio and see you
those watching on YouTube livestream or
watching on the Dave Ramsey show app can
see you but so I think I know what you
are but you're gonna have to tell
everybody well Dave I'm dressed as the
envelope system because I'm the nerd and
I'm the free spirit so I'm dressed as a
hippie perfect that's great that's good
very good I love it and here to do your
debt-free scream in style no less yes
sir well done how much debt have you
paid off forty two thousand six hundred
and sixty three dollars love it not not
bad for a free spirit got it nailed
right down with a dollar girl and how
long did this take this took 40 months
okay and your range of income during
that time so we started right around
43,000 and now bring home a little bit
over 80 very good Wow almost doubled
your income so what do you guys do for a
living I'm a special education teacher
in Williamson County oh yeah okay and
I'm a data analyst with the Tennessee
National Guard and I'm graduate student
at Lipscomb University okay very cool so
what kind of debt was the forty three
thousand dollars we had just around
thirty four thousand and student loans
we had a seventy five hundred dollar car
loan and then surprisingly most people
don't realize in their cell phone plants
or iPhone 6's cost $1,200 so we paid
that down pretty quick okay you know
that'll jump right in there on yet for
sure okay
and did a lot of stuff happen during
this 40 months tell me the story so we
took the class after we got married it
was at our church and so we took the
class and went through the program that
was up in Indiana and so then we moved
down to Nashville so we had the move in
there and originally Alex wanted to
pursue music he was he is a drummer and
that was the plan and so after being
here that dream kind of faded as it does
for some people
and so then kind of got on a different
track with more of a financial mindset
and so that big jump and income really
helped us out yeah that changed
everything so most of this has paid off
in the last little while then the
intensity increased and the income
changed and all that kind of stuff as
you move through the process but you've
been married a little over three years
then correct and you took Financial
Peace University back in Indiana we did
and we took it again here in Nashville
at journey church okay very cool very
cool well pastor Jamie is a good friend
of mine matter of fact I'll see him this
weekend coming
awesome hey well very good you guys
alright so when people hear you paid off
$43,000 making 43 to 80 and they say how
did you do that what do you tell them
the answer is when you tell them a
secret is the biggest thing is budgeting
and assigning every dollar to given
category it was very easy for us to not
even know where money was going month to
month without having that budget mm-hmm
the other big thing is of course
discipline plays a huge part in the
journey but having a goal at the very
end of the program actually writing it
down revisiting it and reassuring each
other quite a few times is what kept us
going and kept that intensity rolling
yeah what about you Murray
well with being the free spirit I
definitely wanted to splurge at times
and being in Nashville there's so many
fun things to do going out to eat and
being social and so there was a lot of
nice fur like you know what let's just
stay in watch a movie make our own food
and so we kind of had to say no a few
times but ended up being a cool thing
because we would say that to our friends
say you know this month we're short on
cash we can't do that and so they ended
up saying you know we're kind of in the
same boat let's just do something
different and so we just kind of had to
be creative and coming up with lots to
do yeah very cool fun very good that's
the that's what you do it's a it's being
intentional and you said you had to have
a goal was there a goal beyond getting
out of debt why were you getting out of
debt so that we can retire young mm-hmm
and have energy to do things and retire
stress-free I'm a big financial guy
I love finances so that was very
intriguing and I had a lot of really
great mentors through the past five to
ten years and some were really great the
finances some weren't so much so I was
able to kind of witness the good the bad
and then kind of pave our own path and
figure out where we wanted it to be I
think ultimately to give you know that
cliche line of you know live and give
but it's so true you know we want to
give back to people in need and so now
we have the freedom to do that and so
it's amazing through this whole process
we learned that tithing was kind of a
discipline that we needed to stick with
and when we would stop doing it we
realized we were kind of without but
when we were always consistent with our
tithe you know God always provided for
us and so we want to you know continue
to up our giving and and find more ways
to do that the correlation on that is
mind-boggling after having watched
people do it and Sharon and I have
having tithe for you know 25 30 years
now and watched literally tens of
thousands of people directly hands on
but millions of people indirectly
through what I do the correlation
between giving steadily for instance for
those of us that are evangelical
Christians tithing 1/10 of our income to
our local church the correlation between
that and financial success is unreal and
it's not like you know like God just
gives you money like you don't have to
work or something you can just sit and
you know go to the mailbox and they'll
be free money there that's not what I'm
talking about it's not something weird
it's just that giving changes the way
you look at the world and it changes the
way you handle money as a result so very
cool very cool well congratulations you
guys thank you well we're gonna give you
a signed copy of Chris Hogan's retire
inspired book of course Paul says that's
the next chapter in your book the first
chapter is debt free the next chapters
become very wealthy and you know like
you said be outrageously generous in the
process so very well done we'll give you
a copy of that as well and you guys win
the award for best costume of the week
it's Monday so it's still early but uh
but I think I think you're probably
gonna win it because I'm guessing nobody
else dresses up with envelopes and has a
hippie the rest of the week at least I'm
kind of hoping they don't for the rest
of the week I'm glad you did it though
on Halloween
very well done very well done all right
Alex and Marie from Nashville Tennessee
the nerd and the free spirit $43,000
paid off in 40 months making 43 to 80
count it down
let's hear a debt free scream 3 this is
how it's done right here hey guys thanks
for watching if you enjoyed this video
click the subscribe button to get the
latest content and check out these other
great clips from the show